Tuck turns. Most of us learn them and
forget them when we're beginners.
They're pretty simple move after all.
Just tuck the poi over and under your
shoulders as you go around in place. And
sure, there are some variations of them
that we may pick up from time to time.
But what if I told you that there is one
variation that nobody knew existed, but
has been hiding in plain sight for
years? Come down the rabbit hole with
me.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Drex here from Drexfactor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I am going to
unlock a secret tuck turn that we have
known about for years but just didn't
connect the dots on. But before we dive
in, I just want to give a quick shout
out to the friends of the channel. Big
thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroera Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all of these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video. So,
first and foremost, let's define what
we're talking about here. When I'm
referring to tuck turns, I am referring
to this kind of poi pattern where I am
tucking the poi behind my shoulders and
up underneath my armpit as I carry my
hands around in a circle around my body.
We can have presentations of this where
we move our hands straight back and
forth in a line along different surfaces
of our body or we can take it around in
a narrow or more broad circle if we so
choose. For most people, I think that
this variation right here is the one
that they will usually think of when we
talk about tuck turns. But there's
something really interesting about it.
Namely, the poi are always spinning in
together time or together same. So, does
that mean that we can take tuck turns
into a place where we're using other
timing and direction modes, too? Why
yes? Yes, it does. And by the way, if
the phrase timing and direction sounds
like Greek to you, don't worry about it.
You'll see what I'm talking about
throughout the rest of this video. But I
also do have a video discussing what
timing and direction is that I'll go
ahead and link to up in the cards as
well as down in the description if you
want to catch up. So the secret that
unlocks part of this is realizing that
when we perform tuck turns, they're
really just flowers. Namely, they are
two petal inspin flowers. The big
difference is that we're tucking those
petals over our shoulders as well as
under our armpits as we take them
around. So in a lot of respects, you can
think of them as just being the same as
this pattern, but adding a body tracer
edge to them. So with that in mind, we
already know that we can take our
flowers into multiple timing and
direction modes. We can do them in
together opposites. We know that we can
do them in split time opposites. And we
know that we can do them in split time,
same direction. So does it follow then
that we can perform our tuck turns in
all four timing and direction modes as
well? Well, yes. but it gets tricky in
at least one case. So, let's take a look
at some of the other cases first.
Starting with together opposites. This
is just spinning the poi in opposite
directions. And you'll note I'm doing
this with my butterflies going outward
rather than inward. I just find it's a
little easier to do it this way. And
technically speaking, we could make the
argument that performing our vertical
snakes like so constitutes a kind of
tuck turn. The biggest challenge there
is though that we're really only
performing the pedal behind with one
hand at a time. So even though I'm
tucking my right hand behind here, I am
not tucking it behind when I get up top.
So while this looks pretty elegant, I
think that it kind of stretches the
bounds of what we would refer to as a
tuck turn. That said, it's absolutely
possible if we perform both of the tucks
at the same time that we can take our
tuck turns completely into together
opposites or butterfly like this. Once
upon a time, I told a student that this
is the together opposite solution for
tuck turns, but that nobody does it, so
it wasn't worth learning. And of course,
once I did that, I wound up writing an
enormous amount of choreography that
used this specific method for doing tuck
turns. So yeah, that was a comment that
didn't age well. And interestingly
enough, the split time opposite solution
looks quite a bit like the snakes that
we take from side to side in split time
opposites. You can either perform them
as full flowers like this, or you can
take them straight across your body like
so, which interestingly enough is a clue
for the final timing and direction mode
that we're going to play with here. But
I originally saw this in a video way
back in maybe 2008, I want to say, and
couldn't understand what was going on.
All I understood is that the performer
was tucking the poi underneath their
armpit and over their shoulder, which,
you know, the underneath the armpit
thing is one thing a lot of people
struggle with when learning this. And it
was learning this in split-time
opposites that really brought home for
me exactly how to make that work in a uh
more controlled and concerted fashion. I
will say that that helped in getting
down the tuck turns in all of the other
timing and direction modes, too. So,
thank you to split time opposites for
making that happen. All right, so we've
waited long enough. There's one more
timing and direction mode that we
haven't talked about. And yes, it is
split time same direction. So, for the
longest time, I thought that the closest
thing to a solution for a tuck turn in
split time, same direction would be
this, where we switch back and forth
between a windmill and a watermill.
There's just one problem. I enter my
windmills going clockwise with my left
hand tucking behind first. And I enter
my watermills going clockwise with my
right hand tucking behind first. As you
might be able to see here, this means
that I have to add an extra half a beat
on either side in order to complete the
move, which turns this into a three
pedal inspin rather than a two pedal in
spin. So, I always told my students that
this was as much a uh a kind of
stretching the boundaries thing as that
uh together opposites uh snake that goes
up the sides of our bodies and just kind
of called it as best we could do for the
longest time. And then I connected some
dots. So, you remember our split time
opposites tuck turns and how much they
looked like our snakes in split-time
opposites? Well, many of us when we're
first learning how to do snakes are
trying to learn how to do these snakes
right here when we're spending the poi
in split time same direction. And guess
what? If the split time opposites snakes
feel a lot like tuck turns, the split
time same direction snakes kind of do as
well. There's all the essentials there.
We're moving our hands both up and down
as well as side to side. And we're
tucking the poi behind our shoulder and
up behind our armpit as we go back and
forth. The biggest thing is we don't
really have a lot of latitude in
bringing our hands up and down. I can
kind of exaggerate this a little bit.
And hey, would you look at that? Now
they actually look like a real tuck
turn. Of course, we can go back to our
classical presentation of them and just
have our hands go straight out to either
side. But both of these count, which is
kind of awesome because split time, same
direction snakes are a thing that have
been around for more than a decade. And
I never thought of them in this context.
And structurally speaking, they hold on
to all of the same stuff that we see in
the other tuck turns. Namely, that we're
tucking both of the poi at the exact
same time. And also too, that we are
getting tucks happening top and bottom
just like we do in split time opposites.
Just so happens to be that we are doing
it in ways that allow us to take our
hands from center outward. But if you
want to think of it this way, you can
also think of it as our hands tracing
around circles going outward and inward
in sync with each other like so. Or just
keep it simple, right? So, what do you
think, friends? Is this a new solution
to tuck turns or am I grasping at straws
here? Please leave me a comment and let
me know. And if you dug the video,
please make sure to like, share, and
subscribe to help other people find the
video and of course to help my channel
grow.
>> [music]
[music]
>> This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my FL patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for your very generous support. And if
you out there watching would like to get
your name in the credits or access to a
whole host of other awesome rewards, you
can do that by heading on over to my
Patreon at patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. I will leave the link to
that down in the description as well as
up in the cards. Please help me out in
my mission of bringing po spinning and
flow arts to the whole wide world. Thank
you in advance. And if you'd like to
learn how to do tuck turns, something I
didn't talk about in this video, I will
go ahead and link to a tutorial on that
move up here on screen as well as down
in the description. Thank you so much
for watching. Please make sure to get
out and flow today and I'll see you with
a new video real soon. Take care [music]
now and happy new year. Peace.